[Música]
el presidente ruso vladimir putin acusa
a occidente de querer llevar a su maíz a
un conflicto armado con ucrania
rompiendo el silencio de las últimas
semanas el líder del kremlin aseguró que
eeuu y la otan ignoraron sus demandas en
materia de seguridad para desescalar las
tensiones
pero tiene el nuevo jefe de gabinete y
el presidente pedro castillo nombró a
héctor valero luego de la renuncia de la
primera ministra mirtha vásquez y de
tres altos funcionarios más porque lo
obligó a formar su tercer gabinete y a
posesionar a una decena de ministros
la oms advierte que muchos países no han
alcanzado el pico de la ola de contagios
desatada por la variante omicron y se
declaró preocupada por la relajación de
medidas entretanto el organismo alertó
de los efectos que generan miles de
toneladas de desechos creados durante la
pandemia
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
maría clara calle los saluda y
comenzamos hablando del presidente ruso
vladimir putin quien acusó a estados
unidos ya sus aliados de ignorar las
demandas de seguridad del kremlin en
medio del temor sobre una eventual
invasión a ucrania washington respondió
que mantiene la puerta abierta al
diálogo mientras líderes europeos como
el británico boris johnson reiteraron su
apoyo aquí es daniela blando tiene los
detalles sobre los hechos más recientes
relacionados con las tensiones entre
moscú y occidente
vladimir putin rompió un silencio que
duró casi seis semanas en su primera
declaración pública relacionada
directamente con la crisis con kiev
desde el 23 de diciembre el presidente
ruso planteó la posibilidad de que
ucrania sea admitida en la otan un
escenario que para él desencadenaría un
conflicto bélico putin aseguró que sigue
abierto al diálogo pero acusó a las
potencias occidentales de crear un
escenario para la guerra
no vemos un reconocimiento genuino de
nuestras tres demandas clave impedir la
expansión de la otan cancelar el
despliegue de armas cerca de las
fronteras rusas y devolverlas
instalación militares del bloque a sus
posiciones en
1997 cuando se firmó el acta fundacional
de rusia
recién la casa blanca mantiene una
posición inflexible en especial en lo
relativo a la expansión de la otan hacia
el este de europa
no sabemos qué va a hacer el presidente
putin y es nuestra responsabilidad y un
imperativo mantener la puerta de la
diplomacia abierta es nada mienta we are
going to be
eso no implica que no vamos a defender
nuestros propios valores que incluyen
nuestra creencia y la de los países de
la otan de que depende de los miembros
de la otan determinar quién puede unirse
y esa puerta debe permanecer abiertas
embolsen yo genera en la ciudad sirve
open las apuestas hasta el momento
apuntan a la vía diplomática el primer
ministro británico boris johnson fue
hasta quiero para mostrar su solidaridad
al presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski desde donde aseguró que una
eventual invasión rusa ucrania
representaría un desastre y en
conversación paralela pero telefónica el
canciller ruso sérguei lávrov reiteró su
posición a su homólogo estadounidense
anthony blinken moscú ha concentrado más
de 100 mil soldados en la frontera
mientras quien que ha llamado a no
sembrar el pánico anunció que aumentará
sus fuerzas armadas en 100.000 efectivos
durante los próximos tres años el
presidente peruano pedro castillo nombró
a héctor valer como el nuevo jefe de
gabinete y posicionó a 18 ministros más
todo esto luego de la ola de renuncias
las más recientes fueron las del
secretario de la presidencia carlos
jayco y del ministro
y finanzas pedro francke la crisis
ministerial en perú se desató tras la
renuncia de la primera ministra mirtha
vásquez y del ministro del interior-
avelino guillén previamente desde lima
nuestro corresponsal francisco zacarías
nos explicó quiénes son las principales
figuras de este nuevo gabinete y cuáles
son sus desafíos el finalmente primer
ministro de perú héctor balear pintó es
un congresista es abogado de profesión
ingresó al parlamento por el partido de
derecha renovación popular y luego se
retiró para formar la agrupación pero
democrático que apoya al presidente
pedro castillo y otro personaje que
sobresale pero no precisamente por sus
logros profesionales es el actual nuevo
ministro del interior y alfonso chávarry
quien está alfonso chávarry es un ex
oficial de la policía peruana quien es
cuestionado por tener una sentencia por
abuso de autoridad en la institución
policial y también por tener dos
procesos por tráfico ilícito de drogas
el principal desafío de este nuevo
gabinete va a ser obtener el voto de
confianza
en 30 días cuando se presenta al
parlamento para presentar su plan de
gobierno desde ya diversos congresistas
han adelantado que no piensan apoyar un
gabinete ministerial en el cual uno de
sus integrantes es una es policía que
está implicado con casos de tráfico
ilícito de drogas
el presidente de eeuu joe biden inició
un proceso de consultas sobre la
nominación de su eventual candidata a
ocupar el puesto del saliente juez
supremo stephen breyer el mandatario
habló sobre el nombramiento con el
presidente del comité judicial del
senado dictamen y con el republicano de
mayor rango del comité shock graceling
ambos políticos clave en el proceso de
confirmación lo mismo hizo en una
llamada telefónica con el líder de la
minoría republicana en el senado mitch
mcconnell hayden aseguró que buscaba una
persona con carácter y con una filosofía
jurídica que entendiera que hay derechos
no enumerados en la constitución el
mandatario ha prometido que va a
postular a la que sería la primera mujer
afroamericana en el máximo tribunal
y en noticias del cob y 19 de la
farmacéutica pfiezer inició un proceso
para solicitar las autoridades
sanitarias estadounidenses que aprueben
la aplicación de su vacuna a menores de
5 años
la multinacional le pidió a la fed que
autorice una dosis que sólo contiene una
décima parte de la inoculación
tradicional contra el coronavirus si el
organismo acepta cerca de 19 millones de
niños menores de 5 años que hay en eeuu
podrían verse beneficiados ya que es la
única población que falta por incluir en
el programa de vacunación estadounidense
y las muertes por ccoo y 19 están
aumentando en todo el mundo la alerta la
dio la organización mundial de la salud
su director pedro ramón libre jesús
rechazó las falsas afirmaciones de que
ya no es posible prevenir la transmisión
del virus y advirtió que todavía es
prematuro que los países comiencen a
cantar victorias sobre la pandemia
en sang andrés nos preocupa que en
algunos países se haya arraigado una
narrativa de que debido a las vacunas de
la alta transmisibilidad y menor
gravedad de omicron ya no es posible ni
necesario prevenir la transmisión nada
estaría más lejos de la verdad sed
nací en el werder from the truth
more transmisión means modo de
transmisión significa más muertes no
estamos pidiendo a ningún país que
regrese al llamado bloqueo pero estamos
pidiendo a todos los países que protejan
a su gente usando todas las herramientas
del conjunto de herramientas no sólo
vacunas es prematuro para cualquier país
rendirse o declarar victoria adsense
habló
exprima your for any country ayer
suspender or to live let the three y
otra de las preocupaciones de la
organización mundial de la salud es el
incremento de los desechos sanitarios
durante la pandemia un nuevo informe del
organismo revela que la carga de
residuos aumentó diez veces y advierte
del problema no sólo es por la
contaminación del aire y del agua sino
que desechos como jeringas o guantes ya
utilizados exponen a cientos de personas
en el mundo juan pabló lucumí nos
explica
la batalla contra el hobbit 19 ha traído
una nueva amenaza para el medio ambiente
y la salud pública un informe de la
organización mundial de la salud señala
que decenas de miles de toneladas de
desechos de material médico que en algún
momento fueron utilizados para combatir
el coronavirus se acumulan en vertederos
y se convierten en un gran problema
descubrimos que el kobe 19 ha aumentado
la carga de residuos sanitarios en las
instalaciones hasta 10 veces los
volúmenes actuales y se considera que 2
de cada 3 instalaciones sanitarias en
los países menos desarrollados no tenían
un sistema para segregar o tratar de
forma segura los residuos el informe
señala que aproximadamente 87 mil
toneladas de equipos de protección
personal adquiridos entre marzo de 2020
y noviembre de 2021 terminarán en
desechos después de ser utilizados
además de contaminar el aire y el agua
de las comunidades que viven cerca de
los vertederos mal gestionados toneladas
de jeringas desechadas kits de pruebas
usados guantes y frascos de vacunas
exponen a múltiples riesgos a los
trabajadores sanitarios ante esto la
organización propone algunas
no utilizar guantes para la vacunación y
otras interacciones en las que los
guantes no sean necesarios utilizar
vidrio y otros envases más ecológicos y
aumentar el uso de artículos seguros
reutilizables en particular máscaras
seguras reutilizables para el público en
lugar de máscaras desechables el reporte
llega en un momento clave cuando el
sector sanitario enfrenta presiones para
reducir su huella de carbono y disminuir
la cantidad de desechos
y con esta noticia de los otros efectos
de la pandemia terminamos nuestra
emisión informativa los invitamos a que
sigan conectados a la señal de france 24
y nos vemos en minutos
[Música]